Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wie geht's dir ach mir
geht's gut ich habe viel Zeit ich lese
ganz viel ich habe die zum ersten Mal in
meinem Leben wenn auch nur online den
Nordkurier gelesen
wie hast Du bislang nicht das ist der
Nordkurier gibt
ich weiß nicht ob dir das so so klar ich
bin ein Fan von Lokalzeitung ich hab
total ich auch die haben übrigens auch
ein ziemlich Boom ja also
zeitungssterbenskrise und geredet ja
Regionalzeitung stehen im Vergleich zu
den überregionalen Zeiten ja da gibt's
Leute die die ich kriege das immer mit
wenn so Medienpreise und so weiter
vergeben werden da gibt's eine neue
Generation von sehr guten
JournalistInnen viele Frauen tatsächlich
aber auch viele Männer die also junge
Männer die sich da jetzt wirklich sehr
reinhängen und das entdeckt haben und
dann auch sehr kreativ sein sollte jetzt
nicht so tun dass wir das alles ganz
easy aber die machen das gut und ich ich
fand halt immer schon so ich mag das
auch wenn du so so kleine Lokalradios
hast und so weiter ja die Dinge die Du
dort berichten kannst die kannst du
nirgendwo anders berichten weil jede
große Zeitung immer sagen würde sehr
viel zu klein interessiert doch in
Bayern kein wenn du jetzt irgendwie weiß
ich nicht in Brandenburg sitzt zum
Beispiel aber
die kleine Lokalzeitung unter
Anführungszeichen kann das machen und
und hat dadurch eine unheimliche
Verankerungen so eine Region und das
finde ich irgendwie schön man macht das
auf und weiß wer gestorben ist und
werden nicht nur das ne also auch
Skandale aufgedeckt auf lokaler Ebene
die dann sich zu großen Sachen ausgeweit
ich war ja jahrelang in der Jury beim
Henry nannten Preis wir haben da
manchmal hervorragenden
Lokaljournalisten ja aber jetzt war der
Nordkurier gerade nicht so gut ja weil
weil natürlich schön ist ist das
Redakteur das nordkuriers unseren
Podcast hören und haben auch Skandal
aufgedeckt ja nicht recht geißelt
Brandenburg
viel Mühe gegeben ja eine ganze Stunde
lang fast über Brandenburg zu schwärmen
ja was dein Südtirol ist ja die die
sozusagen die die die Heimat deiner
Seele deine herzenslandschaft das ist
für mich ja wirklich Brandenburg ja also
wenn man mich irgendwo treffen will dann
sieht man mich irgendwo im Sommer mit
einem Fernglas irgendwo in Brandenburg
stehen und ich meine das völlig ernst
kein einziges böses Wort habe ich über
Brandenburg verloren aber es heißt ich
hätte Brandenburg geistelt und das würde
ich jetzt mal sagen ne wir haben beim
letzten Mal ja das Thema alamismus schon
angerissen das ist natürlich Alarmismus
weil das ja Fake News sogar ja jetzt
wird's noch schöner
jetzt kommt die Verwertung Nummer 2
Alarmismus Nummer 2 Jan rettmann ich
wusste nicht wer das ist dass der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der
brandenburgischen CDU der liest den
Nordkorea hört aber offensichtlich
unserem Podcast nicht und hat wirklich
geglaubt ich hätte Brandenburger
geeignet und gleich mit genau und hat
mich ein unerträglichen Klugscheißer
genannt und dann hat er mich mal belehrt
dass die Bevölkerung in Brandenburg gar
nicht rückläufig ist ja ja sondern
tatsächlich ein bisschen zunimmt und das
stimmt ja die nimmt zu direkt in Berlin
die Leute die Mieten in Berlin nicht
mehr zahlen können
Brandenburg aber in diesen schönen
Gegenden über die ich hier gesprochen
habe so nördlich von Oranienburg und so
weiter werden die Leute Gott sei Dank
dass ich ja gut finde der hat findet das
ganz schrecklich oder weniger weil dann
ist mehr Platz für Natur
ja so ist das und das was kommt
natürlich dabei raus wenn Politiker
Twitter und du kennst ja meine Meinung
Politiker sollten um jegliche Form von
Alarmismus Vorschub zu leisten und um
sich nicht selbst zu belasten erstens
keine Podcasts zu machen fräule
Lamprecht ist grüßen ja auch kein
Video-Podcast und sie sollten nicht
twittern um sich nicht selbst zu
belasten Herr rettmann das war totaler
Unsinn auf der Basis von uns ist also
ich sag mal so der Skandal Nummer 3 den
hast du ja haben wir dann nächste Woche
ja Richard David Precht fordert ja
Politikern Twitter verbinden ja genau
genau
das ist übrigens auch ein zwei Lieblings
Formulierung es gibt ja es gibt ja
mosern Geißeln und fordern und
attackieren noch gibts an attackiert
genau ja ja genau oder beleidigt oder so
oder willst gegen aber so so all diese
Sachen die regt zum Nachdenken an sie
wird über ja und so weiter diese ganzen
Formulierungen sind aus dem Journalismus
verschwunden ich weiß nicht ob sie hier
drin waren aber ich finde sie nicht mehr
aber weißt du was Richard ich
war überrascht du hast es auch eben
mitgekriegt unsere letzte Folge wo wir
tatsächlich so ein bisschen auch über
Alarmismus geredet haben und das war ja
irgendwie so mein mein Grundgedanke mit
dem ich in diese in dieses Gespräch
letztes Mal reingegangen bin so dieser
Frust darüber dass nur noch Apokalypse
ist ja und und lass es uns Alarmismus
nehmen nennen das war die erfolgreichste
Ausgabe die wir je gemacht haben also
offensichtlich haben wir da irgendwie
eine Nerv getroffen und deswegen würde
ich heute die Gelegenheit gerne mal
ergreifen mit dir wirklich mal über
Alarmismus zu sprechen und die Frage
warum wir so empfänglich sind für
allermeismus warum auf der anderen Seite
die dies machen
Medien Politiker und so weiter dem der
Versuchung so schwer widerstehen können
wie also die die Wirkweise von von
Alarmismus ist
und ich würde gerne heute mal mit dir
darüber reden du erinnerst dich ich habe
mich letztes Mal über Antonio guteres ja
ich lege mich jetzt im Kantone guteres
an ich mache das dann mal ganz groß Tim
UN-Generalsekretär der sagt dir wir
stehen vor aktuellen Herausforderungen
die sich Türmen wie Autos bei einer
Massenkarambolage ja der der Welt
attestiert hat sie seid ihr denn
bedauernswerten Zustand das Gefühl es
wird alles immer schlimmer und nicht
regt das mittlerweile es regt mich nicht
auf aber es macht mich zu Sehens
verzweifelt weil ich denke das kannst
doch nicht sein dass wir als Botschaft
in eine Welt hinein senden immer weit es
wird alles immer fürchterlicher wie
erlebst du das ja
sehr schön dass wir darüber reden ich
finde das hat ganz viele verschiedene
Aspekte also erstmal muss man über
Alarmismus grundsätzlich sagen es ist ja
ein Schimpfwort ne also kein Mensch der
alarmistisch ist hält sich für
allermistisch sondern alarmistisch sind
immer die anderen deren Positionen einem
nicht passen Karl Lauterbach ist
alarmistisch ja der ist aller mystisch
weil er hier wegen Corona und so weiter
das sagt er natürlich nicht von sich
selbst er würde sagen er ist besonders
gewissenhaft oder ist vorsichtig oder so
ne auf der Gegenseite ist das
allerwismus und das ist im Grunde
genommen in der Diskussion immer also
Alarmismus wird als Schimpfwort benutzt
ne also alarmistisch ist die starke
Position der anderen
ist nie meine eigene Position das sollte
man vielleicht vorweg schicken und das
zweite ist wir haben ja beim letzten Mal
schon ein bisschen angerissen also wird
die Welt immer schlechter oder wird sie
nicht immer schlechter und das ist ein
ziemlich dickes Brett also auf der einen
Seite kann man sagen es gibt viele Dinge
wir haben beim letzten mal darüber
gesprochen es gibt relativ zur
Weltbevölkerung deutlich weniger junge
Menschen die Armut leben es gibt relativ
zur Weltbevölkerung mehr gebildete
Menschen als jemals zuvor auf dem
Planeten es gibt relativ zur
Weltbevölkerung
ein sehr starkes anwachsendes
gesundheitsstatuses medizinische
Versorgung und so so ich habe das schon
sehr oft auch gesagt es gibt ja zwei
Bücher das von Wrestling fact fulness
genau und von Stephen pinker Aufklärung
Aufklärung Aufklärung jetzt genau und
die beide 218 rausgekommen sind und wo
sich auch viele darüber gefreut haben
und die eigentlich sagen es wird immer
eigentlich immer alles immer besser und
mir ist aufgefallen wenn ich diese
Position eingenommen habe in
Diskussionen häufig mit linken und dass
sie sich sehr über mich aufgeregt haben
weil wenn man das so sagt dann klingt
das immer so beschwichtigend
und natürlich sind die man sich mit dem
Zustand der Welt zufrieden geben
ja das ist die erste Gefahr ist man
harmonisiert ja die zweite ist man
untertreibt weil natürlich wenn zwei
Dinge nie verwechseln darf die relativen
Zahlen und die absoluten Zahlen
natürlich sind die absoluten Zahlen der
Menschen die in Armut leben nach wie vor
wahnsinnig groß weil die Bevölkerung auf
dem Planeten wächst und wächst und
wächst ja die relativen Zahlen geringer
werden das stört diejenigen als
Gegenargument die ja sagen ja aber
Moment mal gucken ob man das so ein
Skandal das in der heutigen Zeit wo man
die ganze Bevölkerung satt machen könnte
ist immer noch hungern gibt das
Entscheidende ist also folgendes unsere
Sensibilität das habe ich auch schon
häufiger gesagt und das ist wichtig
unsere Sensibilität für das was sein
darf und sein soll auf der Welt
die ist massiv gestiegen und weil die
massiv gestiegen ist sehen wir das was
schiefläuft heute viel dramatischer als
das frühere Generationen gesehen haben
ja und da gibt es so eine neue wie soll
man sagen so ein ja so eine so eine
Hoffnungslosigkeit die sich da bereit
macht ich habe dieser Tage mit Lars
Heider im im Thalia Theater hier in
Hamburg wird ein sehr schönen Abend ein
schönes Gespräch über über Politik und
die Welt im Allgemeinen und ähm wir
haben darüber gesprochen dass in in
unserem in unserer Jugend schon ein paar
Tage her aber da war sozusagen der Satz
in diese Welt werde ich doch keine
Kinder setzen das war ein Satz den wir
häufig gehört haben ne atomare Bedrohung
ich meine Seiten frühen 60ern genau und
dann gab es aber nicht Zeit so eine
glückliche Phase und die ist für mich
sehr verbunden mit der Zeit von Angela
Merkel wo es irgendwie pl dich so lief
ja mir letztes Mal auch darüber
gesprochen
dieses Gefühl Mutti wird das schon
irgendwie richten und und läuft jetzt
irgendwie so weiter und jetzt machen wir
plötzlich auf und merken ist nicht mehr
so in der Zeit hat man diesen Satz so
gut wie nicht mehr gehört und plötzlich
fing die Deutschen auch an wieder Kinder
zu kriegen Ursula von der Leyen die
siebenfachste Mutter Deutschlands wie
sie der Spiegel mal genannt hat war
Familienministerin ja und siehe da auch
alle anderen gingen hin und vermehrten
sich ja und jetzt hast du plötzlich
wieder in dieser sehr jungen Generation
hörst du diesen Satz wieder dieses ich
kann doch in diese Welt keine Kinder
setzen und so weiter wirklich rückläufig
ich sehe so viele sehr junge Paare mit
Kindern ich rede über das Gefühl ich
hatte über so ein Lebensgefühl dass ich
sozusagen gerade weil du junge Leute
sagst breit macht und da gibt's
einige aufsehenerregende Studien dazu ja
also junge Leute die Klima Angst haben
beispielsweise also wirklich definiert
als die Angst vor dem Untergang des
Planeten ja und die habe ich auch also
da muss man gar nicht jung führen kann
man ja also musst du mal die Frage
stellen was verstehen wir ganz konkret
unter Untergang des Planeten
wir eher so ich denke so dass Szenario
was ich als Bedrohung wahrnehme und
völlig ernst nehme ist die totale
Austrocknung der Gebiete südlich der
Sahara zum Beispiel also wir haben ja
jetzt schon im Mittelmeerraum auch in
Spanien und auf Sizilien und so weiter
ganz merkwürdige Temperaturen also fällt
ja zum Teil im Sommer keine Tropfen
Regen mehr und so weiter über 40 Grad
die Durchschnittstemperaturen im
mediterran sind höher und besonders
dramatisch es ist südlich der Sahara
ziemlich ziemlich viele Menschen und auf
deren Eckern nichts mehr wächst
und das wird zu gigantischen
Migrationsbewegungen führen weil dort
einfach die Lebensgrundlagen zerstört
werden und das finde ich es jetzt keine
große Spekulation und ich meine wenn wir
nicht wie Beatrix von Storch mal
empfohlen hatte eine Mauer bauen und
darunter Schießen auf die Leute die
kommen
dann weiß ich nicht was wir machen
wollen also wir werden eine
Völkerwanderung erleben wie der Planet
noch keine erlebt hat und das wird
natürlich zu also das ist hier wir haben
ja nicht nur die Klimaveränderung wir
haben ja eben auch die sozialen
Verwerfungen wir haben ja schon in
diesen Gebieten jetzt kriege ich glaube
der erste Krieg war denn davor Gegend ja
also im Suchan das war quasi der erste
klimakrieg also Klima bedingt die
Ernteausfälle da waren die wir mit
durften Klimawandel zurückgeführt werden
können und es dazu Massaker und Bürger
kriegen und fürchterlichen Morden und so
weiter gekommen ist wir werden das in
diesen Regionen haben wir werden die
entsprechende Migrationen haben und das
alles der globale Auswirkung das wird
nicht auf Afrika beschränkt sein und das
sind Dinge die kommen zu uns
unweigerlich und da muss man ganz ganz
berechtigt sich Gedanken darüber machen
und zwar ziemlich schnell und ziemlich
intensiver Gedanken aber hier wir reden
ja heute und das ist ja das was so
interessante daran ist also
diese Fakten unbenommen und würde ich
auch im Leben nie bestreiten man könnte
jetzt auch anfangen über den Trades
Gletscher zum Beispiel zu sprechen hat
Anton Hofreiter neulich bei uns in der
Sendung fallen lassen fand ich sehr
interessant weil ich merke oder einem
anderen zusammen
tatsächlich glaube ich ich kriege sie ja
doch muss muss die Sendung gewesen sein
und er liest das plötzlich so fallen und
sagte wir haben da schon ein großes
Problem als Menschheit und ich ich ich
horchte so wirklich auf weil ich dachte
guck mal der beschäftigt sich mit mit
genau diesem Gletscher ich weiß nicht ob
du den Trades Gletscher kennst das ist
ein also als wir 2011 in der Antarktis
darunter am Südpol unterwegs waren ja zu
Fuß für unsere kleine
Fernsehdokumentation mit mit Joey Kelly
der uns unter dem Absingen schlechter
Kelly Songs vorwärts getrieben hat
da haben wir als wir dann zum Pool
gekommen sind mit Klimawissenschaftlern
genau darüber gesprochen die sagten ihre
große Sorge ist die beste Antarktis ja
da liegt unglaublich viel Eis teilweise
5000 Meter hohes dickes Eis kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen und die West
Antarktis war sozusagen dieser
schlafende Riese die große Frage setzt
sich das irgendwann in Bewegung oder
nicht und es war lange Zeit ziemlich
ruhig und in der am Südpol in der in der
in der in der Antarktis gibt es ja
dieses shelf Eis ne dieses gigantische
Chef teilweise 1000 m hohes Eis das aber
auf mehr liegt und dieses Eis verhindert
dass unter anderem dieser Trades
Gletscher sozusagen einfach ungehindert
ins Meer fließen kann jetzt mein ganz
einfachen Worten gesagt und es gibt es
die Befürchtung und das wird seit langer
Zeit beobachtet das genau diese Schäfer
Eis an der Stelle in der Westen
Antarktis binnen fünf bis zehn Jahren
auseinanderbrechen könnte das heißt
diese Barriere wäre dann weg was
bedeuten würde dieser Gletscher dieser
Trades Gletscher in dem Fall hat freie
Bahn muss dir vor das ist ein Gletscher
nur dieser Gletscher ist so gigantisch
ist er so groß ist wie ganz
Großbritannien das macht man sich gar
nicht klar die ganze Antarktis ist fast
doppelt so groß wie Australien ja also
das hat diese Dimension und weil das Eis
ist das ja sozusagen auf einem Kontinent
liegt der wenn der Nordpol abschmilzt
ist das traurig aber dann führt das
nicht zu einer Erhöhung des
Meeresspiegels aber wenn natürlich Eis
abschmilzt das an Land gebunden ist ja
90% der Süßwasservorräte dieses Planeten
dann hast du ein echtes Problem oder das
bei mir Problem Überflutung der ganzen
Millionenstadt haben Äquator genau das
ist das Thema über das du dann redest
auf der einen Seite
wenig Wasser und die anderen haben zu
viel Wasser vor der Haustür so das hat
er dann so nebenbei einfließen lassen
und ich dachte
interessant scheint er sich auch mit
diesem Thema zu beschäftigen und das
will ich auch gar nicht groß in Abrede
stellen und ich finde wir sollten meine
eigene Folge nur über die Klima Song
wirklich machen mir geht es um die
Wahrnehmung mir geht es um die Frage wie
geht man damit umgehen um diesen
Alarmismus um diese Apokalypse ich hatte
wenn du dich erinnerst haben wir schon
ein paar mal drüber gesprochen die die
Carla Rochel bei uns in der Sendung
letzte Generation sehr angenehmes kluges
Mädchen die aber auch genau diesen
Alarmismus verströmt und ja
Milliarden Menschen die sterben werden
und so weiter ist ein ja das kann aber
auch passieren das ist eine Frage in
welcher Zeitraum ist seit dem Zeiträumen
man denkt aber dass man sich darüber
Sorgen macht also ich sage noch mal wir
sind eigentlich diejenigen Jugendlichen
die sich darüber große Sorgen machen
hundertmal lieber als sie die
gedankenlos vor sich jemals keine Frage
mir geht es nur darum was was wird denn
aus dieser Welt wenn wir ernsthaft diese
Hoffnungslosigkeit kann ich könnte dich
jetzt dagegen argumentieren irgendwas
wird denn aus dieser Welt ja wenn wir
das was du Alarmismus nennst nicht haben
sondern denken immer wieder Kölner jetzt
machen wollen
klimaneutral Aschaffenburg und so na das
sind diese Regierungen ja in Partei Name
der Grünen die sich immer weg Marken
setzen jetzt wie 2045 wo keiner von
denen die heute in der Regierung sind
noch in der Regierung sein werden und
dafür auch nicht mehr zur Verantwortung
gezogen werden können also dieser
Alarmismus ist das Gegengift ja gegen
diese sich
abschleifenende Idealismus und
Enthusiasmus der dann so wenn man
jahrelang Verhandlungen geführt hat ob
das mit kohlekonzernen ist oder mit dem
eigenen Koalitionspartner und so weiter
wo man dann so irgendwann so nur noch
stolz auf das kleine ist und das große
aus den Augen verliert und da ist es
quasi das Gegengift genauso das ist so
wie ich das empfinde also ich empfinde
die einen sind sicherlich in ihre
Wortwahl mein junge Leute können sich ja
auch noch nicht in jedem Punkt
präzisesten das Ausdrücken übrigens
viele alte auch nicht ja
das also auf der einen Seite sind
diejenigen mit dem ganzen verzweifelten
Pathos und auf der anderen Seite sind
diejenigen die eigentlich nichts mehr so
richtig aus der Reserve lockt ja und ich
finde die beiden Pole braucht also es
braucht sozusagen den Pool der
Pragmatiker und es braucht den Pool der
radikalen Idealisten damit überhaupt
Bewegung entsteht weil wenn nur noch die
Pragmatiker Übergewicht sind und die
sind in der Politik die Riesen Mehrzahl
mit der praktischen Politik in den
Minister Ämtern stark Sekretäre und so
weiter da wird man nicht viel Idealisten
finden
den Pool und das ist eigentlich mein
Thema du weißt ja ich bin ja ein ich mag
diese junge Leute gerade diese das Kind
zu bescheuert wenn ich das sage aber die
ja so ein bisschen Dunkelhaft ich weiß
aber so ist es nicht gemeint diese die
ich ich habe keine keinen besseren
Ausdruck jetzt gefunden aber diese junge
Generation die danach wächst das sind
echt gute Leute ich ich ich sag das auch
oft öffentlich ich mag die wirklich aus
tiefster Seele gerne weil das Leute sind
die sich Gedanken machen wie du sagst
sie sind idealistisch die kennen die
Argumente die sind geschult die sind
rhetorisch brillant hatten wir immer
wieder haben wir solche Leute auch in
der Sendung sitzen deswegen rede ich so
wahnsinnig gerne mit denen aber was ich
dort eben feststelle und das habe ich
schon bei bei drehreisen auch in den USA
zum Beispiel gesehen in Kalifornien da
gibt es zusehends auch den Pool und
dieser verzweifelten da gibt es so eine
Traurigkeit so eine Melancholie so
dieses die fetischistische wir können
eigentlich eh nichts machen und
eigentlich sind das doch Menschen die
sind gerade sozusagen auf dem Sprung ins
Leben und und das das muss doch etwas
sein von dem du sagst das packe ich
jetzt an und das habe ich Lust zu
gestalten aber da ist nichts mehr mit
Lust am Gestalten das einfach nur noch
Hoffnungslosigkeit
auch das Gefühl dass man also das ist ja
eine Sache die man ernsthaft abwägen
kann ja sind unsere
festgefahrenen alten kann man sagen
Gesellschaften unsere auch recht
verkrusteten Systeme sind die wirklich
in der Lage diese nicht nur jahrhundert
sondern Jahrtausend Herausforderungen
der Menschheit tatsächlich zu
bewerkstelligen und wenn man die
Geschichte zurück guckt und sagt so wann
ging das los dass man klapp of Rome
anfangen der 70er Jahre Gründung der
Grünen Ende der 70er Anfang der 80er
dann so die der steht der Alarmismus der
der produktive übrigens von Greenpeace
und so weiter und dann guckt wie lange
hat das gedauert bis wir ernsthafte
Klimapolitik anfangen zu betreiben die
nicht so ein bisschen schöner als
Chirurgie und krebskranken Patienten ist
sondern wirklich richtige richtige
ernsthafte Klimapolitik da fangen wir so
gerade mit an Markus nach
überflüssig Jahren nach über 40 Jahren
und ich meine dass man dann eine
Verzweiflung hat in der jungen
Generation die denken diese Generation
die jetzt am sind das sind die Leute
überwiegend im Alter von dir und mir ja
die packen das nicht die schaffen das
nicht die kommen aus ihren Gewohnheiten
nicht raus die werden nichts großartiges
ändern egal ob sie Politiker sind oder
Wirtschaftsleute oder so diese
Verzweiflung dass sie denken das ändert
sich nicht wirklich ich es ist nicht so
dass ich das nicht nachvollziehen kann
also ich halte das zumindestens für eine
nachvollziehbare Perspektive ja mit mir
geht's nur darum Georg maskulum den du
auch kennst lange
Chefredakteur beim Spiegel einer den ich
sehr schätze der noch zusammen mit
seiner Frau unter anderem ein paar tolle
Bücher gemacht hat auch als über Corona
oder anderen und so weiter der viel
investigativ Journalismus gemacht hat
also einer der sich wirklich die Mühe
macht jeden Stein einmal umzudrehen der
war gerade
in einem Stück oder einem Interview ich
glaube in einer Rede sogar was genau in
einer Rede hat er davor gewarnt diese
Aufgeregtheit
immer so furchtbar ernst und mit dieser
Aufgeregtheit endlich mal aufzuhören
speziell getriggert durch soziale Medien
ich dachte ja der hat recht guter Punkt
ja aber die Frage wie heißt Medien
müssen wir wirklich über jedes Stückchen
immer drüber springen dass uns
irgendjemand hinhält oder haben wir da
eine Verantwortung der wir zum Teil
nicht wirklich gut Nachkommen ja also da
müssen wir finde ich auch wieder zwei
Sachen unterscheiden also der Alarmismus
über dem wir vorhin Sprachen also die
Leute die die Angst haben davor dass die
Geschichte der Menschheit sich im 21
Jahrhundert ob das Klimawandels
ausziehen könnte ist natürlich eine
andere Art von Alarmismus ja als der
tagtägliche Alarmismus der Medien der
sich mit dem Aufkommen der sozialen
Medien was ja nun das Thema wo ich mich
mit Harald Welzheim letztens genau ja
viel mit beschäftigt habe
ja das heißt also wir leben heute in
einer Gesellschaft in an der in der der
alltägliche Bedarf an außer alltäglichen
ja größer ist als je zuvor das führt
dazu dass alles sensationiert werden
muss weil das sonst nicht wahrgenommen
wird also auch lauter kein Schreiben
genau so und deswegen schreien alle laut
ja nicht zuletzt der Nordkurier noch mal
schöne Grüße ja auf Basis häufig
vernichts oder von wenig ja und das was
ich am Anfang sagte diese diese
Zuspitzung es wird nur noch gefordert ja
oder gemotzt oder so also diese diese
ganze echte Nachdenklichkeit dieses Jahr
in dieser Gesellschaft gibt sehr viele
Leute sind ja in den vielen großen
Fragen über die wir jetzt stehen ja
Waffenlieferung von Leopard Panzern oder
nicht sehr viele Leute die ich kenne
haben da keine holzhackerische Meinung
zu die fordern nichts ja die sind auch
oft nicht radikal irgendwo gegen ja
sondern die reflektieren die haben in
ihrem Kopf Gefühle und Gedanken des
sowohl als auch und das alles bildet
sich in der
Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie unserer
Mediengesellschaft nicht mehr
entsprechend ab
jetzt muss ich mal eben eine Pause
machen leider gehört genau
zwingend dran ich hoffe dass ich das in
fünf Minuten erledigt habe vielleicht
noch schneller ja bis gleich
so Markus da bin ich wieder ich war kurz
zur Tür willkommen
über das nachgedacht was du eben noch
mal sagtest und ich will noch mal
zurückkommen auf hans Rosling ja den den
berühmten schwedischen Statistiker ich
habe noch mal in factool lässt noch mal
nachgelesen das ist ja dieses Buch das
erst nach seinem Tod erschienen ist ja
und das bei mir zu Hause auf dem
Nachttisch liegt weil es ein großartiges
Buch ist und ich ich weiß noch ich habe
vor vor ein paar Jahren bei dem Drehen
Schweden habe ich Anna Mia extra drüben
kennengelernt eine Professorin vom
carolinska Institut die ist Nachfolgerin
von hans Rosling und ich auch so eine
statistikerin und so weiter und ich
sagte wie war denn der unter meinte sie
ja der war so der war so grummelig und
immer wenn man ihm was gesagt hat dann
sagt er immer
das kann so sein aber ich glaube es ist
alles ganz anders
hingucken und das war der Angang von
hans Rosling wenn es sozusagen um den
Blick auf die Welt ging es war ein
toller Mann der war Arzt der ist nach
Liberia gegangen als dort oder in den
angrenzenden Nachbarländern Ebola
ausgebrochen ist und so weiter das war
einer der wirklich Armut aus eigenem
ansehen und eigenem Erleben kannte und
der wusste wovon er redet und der sich
trotzdem und deswegen schätze ich den so
sich immer den guten Blick auf die Welt
bewahrt hat und wenn du dir dieses Buch
anguckst dass ich wirklich sehr sehr
empfehle dass er nicht alleine gemacht
hat sondern mit seinem Sohn und seiner
Schwiegertochter zusammen dann beginnt
das mit einem Christ und allein dieses
Quiz ist so lehrreich wenn es darum geht
die Perspektive auf die Welt zu
verändern z.B mit der Frage Frage an
dich Richert in den letzten 20 Jahren
hat sich der Anteil der Menschen auf der
Welt die extreme Armut 7 a verdoppelt B
wesentlich verändert oder deutlich mehr
als halbiert was wir zusammen ja ich
weiß die Antwort also die Antwort
deutlich mehr als halbiert richtig das
weiß ich deswegen weil der allergrößte
Teil dieser Menschen Chinesen sind ich
weiß aber trotzdem ist es interessant
das mal zu hören oder zum Beispiel
anders weil wir gerade über Klima
Katastrophe gesprochen haben ja das Wort
benutze ich jetzt gerade ganz bewusst
wie hat sich die Zahl der Todesfälle pro
Jahr durch Naturkatastrophen über die
letzten 100 Jahre entwickelt was wird
sie sagen mehr als nur also da würde ich
geblieben hat sich mehr als halbiert
naja weißt du da würde ich ja mal eins
dazu sagen das wissen wir nicht
ehrliche Antwort das können wir nicht
wissen
die arme Menschen bei einem
Vulkanausbruch ein Indonesien 1920
gestorben sind das hat keiner erzählt
also da glaube ich keine Zeit ich glaube
dass wir überhaupt erst also über uns
aber er weiß also man könnte das man
könnte das Sagen im Hinblick auf Europa
da könnte man sagen es liegt deutlich
reduziert natürlich ne weil die Flüsse
nicht mehr so über die Ufer treten war
das alles irgendwie keine helle geworden
sind inzwischen haben wir wieder ein
Problem damit dass das Kanäle geworden
aber global glaube ich jetzt mal ganz im
Ernst das weiß keiner also wie viele
Leute hat Naturkatastrophen am Amazonas
umgekommen sind darüber ist vor 100
Jahren keine Statistiken
nicht ja welche aber trotzdem vorsichtig
jemandem wie crossling zum Beispiel und
seinen Leuten da jetzt die Expertise
abzuschreiben
die wir haben genau so oder wenn du dir
zum Beispiel anguckst ich meine vor vor
100 Jahren ja wer hätte geahnt dass wir
in den 2020er Jahren doppelt so lange
leben wie heute durch Antibiotika und so
weiter die Bewohner der ärmsten Länder
verfügen pro Person mittlerweile über so
viele Kalorien wie Menschen bei uns in
den 60ern ja das bedeutet Hungersnöte
auf der Welt sind deutlich seltener
geworden
ja ja
statistischen Mitteln ja
fünf Jahre in der empirischen Forschung
an der Uni gearbeitet deswegen muss man
immer sehr vorsichtig sein was man da
jetzt genau quasi gemessen hat aber er
so ich bin auf deiner Seite ich hatte
das ja vorhin schon gesagt ja also das
durchschnittliche Leben eines
durchschnittlichen Menschen auf diesem
Planeten
noch nie so gut wie heute ja so und und
so beginnt auch dieser Text er sagt ich
zitiere mal denken sie über die Welt
nach Kriege Gewaltverbrechen
Naturkatastrophen Korruption
schreckliche Dinge passieren und es
fühlt sich anders ob alles immer nur
noch schlimmer wird die Reichen immer
reicher die Armen immer ärmer und so
weiter und die Zahl der Armen nimmt
immer weiter zu bald werden die
Ressourcen ausgehen es sei denn wir
unternehmen was dagegen das ist das Bild
dass die meisten Menschen im Westen in
den Medien sehen oder sind wir sind
genau bei unserem Thema und dass sie in
den Köpfen mit sich rumtragen Häuslingen
nannte das eine überdramatisierte
Weltsicht die belastend ist und
irreführend und jetzt aber noch mal
Stück für Stück die Reichen werden
reichert das sowas von voll ja die armen
werden nicht absolut
ärmer sondern er richtig relativ einfach
aber das ist sehr sehr viele Nachrichten
der Welt in Wirklichkeit
pass auf ich ich ich ich sag dir mal wie
Rosling das deutet und interpretiert in
Wirklichkeit sagt er lebt die große
Mehrheit der Weltbevölkerung irgendwo in
der Mitte der einkommenskala und und
schränkt dann sofort ein und sagt
vielleicht nicht das was wir uns unter
Mittelschicht vorstellen aber ein
extremster Armut leben sie
glücklicherweise nicht die Mädchen gehen
zur Schule erstaunlich viele die Kinder
werden geimpft 80% hätte ich auch nicht
gedacht erstaunlich viele sie leben in
Familien mit zwei Kindern und du weißt
auch die große Apokalypse die häufig so
von rechts kommt also da gibt es in
Afrika diese gigantische
Bevölkerungsexplosion auch da sagt er
und das leuchtet mir völlig ein in
Wahrheit haben wir den Peak
wahrscheinlich schon erreicht weil in
dem Moment wo Bildung zunimmt speziell
Frauen und Mädchenbildung haben können
in dem Moment gehen Geburtenraten unten
das heißt es ist total aller mystisch
und total unseriös zu sagen in Afrika
werden in 50 Jahren noch zwei drei vier
fünf Milliarden Menschen leben und
allein in Nigeria werden so viele
Menschen leben wie in der gesamten
Europäischen Union das ist so nicht
seriös aber das sind die Nachrichten die
du Tag für Tag hörst ja also
interessanterweise dass sich die Kurve
mal abflachen würde das ist
Diskussionsstand seit den 1990er Jahren
das ist nämlich die Zeit wo ich
angefangen habe mich mit Ökologie zu
beschäftigen und mein Thema war ja nicht
Klimawandel mein Thema ist ja
Biodiversität und Atemschutz und solche
Fragen und da hat ist man immer schon
davon ausgegangen dass der Planet sich
dann irgendwann zwischen 10 und 12
Milliarden Menschen einpendeln wird und
jetzt das ganze nicht in der in der
gleichen Geschwindigkeit weiter vorwärts
geht hier ist es wieder eine halb gute
Nacht
gute Nachricht weil es ist zum Beispiel
in einem Land wie Ruanda was also zu den
vorzeigeländern in Afrika gehört ist es
so dass jetzt die Zahl der Kinder pro
Frau nicht mehr beacht Kindern liegt
sondern vielleicht nur noch bei vier
Kindern ungefähr und das ist ein
gewaltiger Fortschritt die Regierung
überlegt ob sie eine drei-kind-politik
einführt weil diese vier Kinder
natürlich immer noch viel zu viel sind
wir haben es hier mit dem Problem zu tun
je größer eine Bevölkerung ist umso
gefährlicher ist es natürlich wenn sie
weiter wächst ja ja und dann sind
natürlich auch drei oder vier Kinder
noch zu viel das heißt also natürlich
der totale Katastrophismus das geht
jetzt ewig so weiter das funktioniert
natürlich richtig ist auch Bildung
Wohlstand gerade Bildung von Frauen
Veränderung Altersvorsorge und so weiter
das sind sehr sehr gute Mittel damit die
Bevölkerung nicht so stark Weg genau und
das ist völlig richtig aber sie wird
noch um einiges mehr Erwachsene ist
schon klar aber die aber die ähm der
interessante Zusammenhang mit der z.B
die Land wie weniger oder Niger guckst
ja je nachdem welches aussprechen wollen
wirklich eines der allerersten Länder
auf diesem Planeten nirgendwo kriegen
Frauen mehr Kinder weil Bildung quasi
kaum erreichbar ist weil die Menschen
wirklich
gesprochen ja vor kurzem erst als ein
Beispiel dafür wo er sich im Augenblick
eine gigantische humanitäre Katastrophe
Hungerkatastrophe unter anderem deswegen
genau es könnte tatsächlich sein dass
also man darf sich ja diese diese Kurven
ne nicht immer so glatt vorstellen also
es ist ja nicht so als wenn jetzt von
Jahr zu Jahr die Verhältnisse auf dem
Planeten besser werden sondern das
könnte rein theoretisch sein dass jetzt
auch meine Phase eintritt von mehreren
Jahren wo keine signifikante
Verbesserung oder gar nicht
Verschlechterung Auftritt ja die
langfristige Tendenz die arbeitet im
Sinne von pinker oder im Sinne von
rossling es bedeutet aber nicht dass
solche Kurven Dellen haben und es gibt
auch keine mathematische Gesetzmäßigkeit
die festlegt dass das auf die gleiche
Weise weitergeht wie in den letzten
Jahrzehnten genau mir geht zu meinen
anderen Punkt Richard bei Geschichte
interessant ist doch wir leben doch in
einer Welt in der wir unendlichen Zugang
zu Information haben und das
Interessante ist das auch Menschen auch
viele Journalisten zum Beispiel Menschen
die wirklich Zugang zu den neuesten
Informationen haben auch die sehen die
Welt nicht mit den Augen von hans
Rosling sondern die sehen die Welt mit
den Augen sozusagen des der der
Katastrophismus mit mit diesen
Weltuntergangsszenarien sozusagen immer
Problembeschreibung und das Problem
maximal dramatisch machen damit es ja da
bist du dann dann schnell beim Netz
damit es klickt ja damit du in dieser
Aufmerksamkeit Ökonomie auf auf deinen
ähm auf deine Kosten kommst
irgendeine Idee oder einen Vorschlag
wieder Journalismus daraus kommt pass
auf ich habe gerade eben bei ja
gedacht
die Problembeschreibung zu machen ist
völlig richtig beim bei der
Klimaveränderung die Problembeschreibung
zu machen ist völlig richtig aber die
Frage ist welche Schlüsse zieht man
daraus und zum Beispiel am Fall von
Niger weil siehst du wir sehen doch wir
wissen doch was wir eigentlich zu tun
hätten und wir sollten uns an die
Arbeiten machen roßling hat übrigens
eine total interessante These und das
interessiert mich deine Meinung Richard
roßling sagt dass das so passiert dass
wir so empfänglich sind für diesen
Alarmismus und für diese ganze
Aufgeregtheit die jetzt natürlich mit
dem Netz an unglaublich mächtiges
Werkzeug bekommen hat er sagt das hat
nichts nur mit der böswürdigkeit von
Medien zu tun mit Propaganda mit Fake
News und noch nicht mal mit falschen
oder mit alternativen Fakten er sagt wie
total interessant
eigentlich hat er die These das hat was
mit der Funktionsweise unseres Gehirns
zu tun dass wir da so so gerne auf der
falschen Spur unterwegs sind also ich
finde das ist keine entweder oder Frage
also weil unser Gehirn weil unser Gehirn
so funktioniert funktioniert das
bestimmt die Dinge wie zum Beispiel das
neue ja oder das das monströse besonders
starke Emotionen in uns auslösen
deswegen funktionieren Medien so wie sie
funktionieren ich würde auch niemals den
Medien böswürdigkeit unterstellen und
das macht
bestimmt ein ganz netter Mensch der das
geschrieben hat und das einfach nur
falsch verstanden hat aber das
Motivation ich übrigens sogar ein
bisschen verstehe ich hat ja der war in
seiner er wollte sozusagen waren seine
Ehre getrennung kommt wahrscheinlich
selber aus Brandenburg ja und hatte
irgendwie das Gefühl dann hätte ich mich
irgendwie unfreundlich drüber geäußert
und ich kann ja nur sagen es war genau
das Gegenteil der Fall nicht ich glaube
das noch mal Lover
Regionen in Brandenburg die weit von
Berlin weg sind sind ein Schatz und sie
sind nicht in erster Linie einen Schatz
für künftige Industrieentwicklung
sondern sie sind ein Schatz auch im
Hinblick auf ökologische Politik als
Naturreservate und ich finde dass ich
Brandenburg tourismusmäßig weit unter
Wert verkauft aber weißt du das war die
Aussage und das hat mich Geißeln
überhaupt gar nichts zu tun dass er was
mit Schwärmen zu tun ist also mit Liebe
mit ja du bist ein Brandenburg
vielleicht ein kritischer Liebhaber
gegenüber Brandenburg aber lieb habe
aber weißt du aus der das interessant
ist doch Richard ich ja immer das vorhin
erzählt hast dachte ich guck mal jeder
von denen ich würde doch dem CDU Mann
z.B jetzt gar nicht zu den billigen
Populismus unterstellen der hat jetzt in
nordkorregeln und heftig twittert ja und
von einem unerträglichen Klugscheißer
spricht obwohl meine Zusammenhang nicht
verstanden hat dem würde ich keine edlen
Motive ich würde sowieso bei twittern
edle Motive eher nicht in Anspruch ich
will nur sagen worauf ich hinaus will
ist aus der Sicht des Politikers wenn du
sagst es ist eigentlich eine gute
Nachricht wenn der plötzlich weniger
Menschenleben und plötzlich mehr Platz
für Wölfe da ist ja auch sehr wichtig
ist Politikers ist das keine gute
Nachricht man mit Wölfen kannst du keine
Politik machen also kannst du schon aber
du kannst nichts gestalten ja du kannst
ein bisschen was gestalten
man kann sowieso nichts gestalten also
erst Fraktionsvorsitzender der das CDU
die CDU hat in Brandenburg 15% der
Stimmen dass sie nicht unter 300.000
Stimmen du findest mehr Schreiadler in
Brandenburg als CDU Wähler also ich
würde nicht glauben dass ich diese Art
und Weise großartig Populismus hast du
gerade machst du nein
das ist wirklich mieses CDU Bashing
überleg doch mal wie gut ist es
eigentlich das Herr rettmann obwohl du
sagst es gibt weniger eine CDU Wähler
als Steinadler ja in drei Adler
Entschuldigung Schreie Adler in
Brandenburg nein das Beispiel ist
natürlich Beispiel also ich muss sagen
Schreiadler sind ja sehr selten das gebe
ich ja gerne zu aber mehr Mäusebussard
als CD ich habe eine andere These ich
glaube ja dass die Mäusebussarde und die
Schreie Adler und Brandenburg und Herr
rettmann und du ihr seid in Wahrheit gar
nicht so weit voneinander entfernt
eigentlich wollt ihr alle nur das Beste
verbrandenburg und sogar der nordkorea
will nur das Beste für Brandenburg und
eigentlich ist das was wir hier gerade
besprechen schönes Beispiel dafür wie
man sozusagen die Mechanismen dieser
Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie Stichwort auch
Alarmismus und so weiter wie man das
nehmen kann und eben benutzen kann und
wenn ihr jetzt an einem Tisch sitzen
würdet und würde miteinander reden wer
das glaube ich ein konstruktives gutes
Gespräch
ja das ist durchaus möglich dass das so
wäre
wenn alle durch die Liebe zu Brandenburg
vereint sind ja werden sie auch eine
gemeinsame Ebene finden
ich finde wir sollten
das jetzt aber nur für uns irgendwie wir
sollten Sticker verticken im zdf-shop
Brandenburg Lover ich glaube das würde
würde
sehr nachgefragt sein wenn geht aber
noch mal noch mal zu zu hans Rosling und
anderen
ich meine
du bist ja jemand der sich viel auch so
mit dem menschlichen Hirn beschäftigt du
hast ja auch dankenswerterweise eins du
setzt es auch sehr intensiv ein und ist
auch richtig was drin in diesem Gehirn
aber willst Du dem zustimmen dass das
der Mensch das wir so gebaut sind dass
wir dass wir sozusagen so empfänglich
sind für alles was steile Thesen sind
was alarmistisch ist was Apocalypse ist
und der Grund warum wir Roland Emmerich
Filme gucken ja also ich finde dass wir
hier nicht schön ja also jeder Jacke ist
anders ich mir fällt gerade mein Vater
ein ja der meidet alles was neu und
monströs ist das heißt es gibt also
offensichtlich auch Gehirne die genau
andersrum
funktionieren und ich muss persönlich
sagen ich gucke keine Emmerich Filme ich
habe also Independence Day gesehen vor
langer Zeit als er raus kam ja und jetzt
schlecht gefunden und von da an um
Emmerich Filme ein riesigen Bogen
gemacht also ich glaube dass wir müssen
wir vorsichtig sein also jedes Gehirn
funktioniert noch ein klein bisschen
anders aber richtig ist natürlich das
könnte man jetzt auch evolutionär
begründen natürlich sind Dinge die die
neu sind in der Savanne war ja wenig neu
wir waren ja nicht reizüberflutet mit
ständigen Neuheiten wenn da mal was neu
war war das natürlich was Besonderes das
wird auf die Gehirne natürlich auch
einen großen Einfluss haben ein
tierisches Gehirn muss sehen dass es
sich auf Neues einstellt und das muss
dem neuen und dem unvorhergesehenen und
dem bedrohlichen demonströsen muss es
Aufmerksamkeit schenken damit man
überlebt
bei uns ist das natürlich dann in so ein
Spaßmodus übergegangen das ist dient ja
nicht mehr dem Überleben ne sondern es
dient ja dann eigentlich so eine
drogenartigen selbstsensationierung
genau und das Gegenteil davon wäre sich
mit Meditation und mit Konzentration und
so weiter da auch irgendwann auch wieder
runterzubringen ne der von mir so häufig
zitierte Lessing Satz wer über gewisse
Dinge den verstanden nicht verliert hat
keinen zu verlieren mit meiner Ergänzung
wer über alles den Verstand verliert
auch nicht ja richtig richtig und und
ich meine wir leben eher in der Welt wo
wir dabei sind über alles den Verstand
suchen wirklich also man kann sich gerne
mal über Brandenburg und die
serengeti-kabeln aber das eben nur in
schwarz und aber dieses ernsthafte sich
ständig über alles bis zum Anschlag
aufzuregen
in politischen Diskussionen dem
politischen Gegner üble Absichten zu
unterstellen so wie du gerade von
Menschen die anderer Meinung sind als
man selber davon ausgehen dass sie total
dumm sind oder bösartig zynisch und so
weiter das hat ein Ausmaß angenommen und
zwar leider auch in den sogenannten
Qualitätsmedien und das ist eben durch
die Twitter Reihe entstanden also ich
halte den Einfluss der twitterei auf den
öffentlichen Diskurs immer noch für
völlig unterschätzt ist das so ja ja ich
glaube leider ja und das Merkwürdige ist
ja es reichen ja wenige massiv hast
erfüllte Kommentare auf Twitter aus um
gigantische gesellschaftliche Folgen
zurzeitigen und macht ohne Missbrauch
verliert ja bekanntermaßen seinen Reiz
und deswegen wird er auch viel Gebrauch
von gemacht also ich werde ihr bei Markt
Twain schöner Satz ich habe in meinem
Leben schon unzählige Katastrophen
durchlebt die wenigsten davon sind
eingetreten
ist ja auch tatsächlich so ja das meine
ich auch tatsächlich so also ich denke
dass man sich in seinem Leben vor
deutlich mehr Dingen fürchtet als dass
diese B Vorrichtung am Ende aufgehen ist
aber auch eine Mentalitätsfrage ja aber
noch mal ne du hast gerade etwas
Interessantes gesagt Richard du sagtest
gerade das Gegengift wäre Meditation ne
ich würde ja immer sagen das Gegengift
ist Recherche also jetzt was unserem
Berufsstand zum Beispiel angeht denkt
man nach wie oft haben wir eigentlich in
den letzten Jahren übrigens auch ich und
darüber gesprochen dass quasi die Lunge
des Planeten stirbt dass der Amazonas
jetzt kaputt geht und das Gefühl dass
immer entstanden ist und es gibt so
viele solche apokalyptischen Berichte
bis heute wenn es mal wieder brennt am
Amazonas also es ist das Gefühl wir
kriegen demnächst alle Schnappatmung
weil es kein Sauerstoff mehr gibt auf
der Welt
und die Wahrheit ist stimmt so nicht
weil der Amazonas braucht einen großen
Teil dieses Sauerstoffs den er
produziert für sich selbst Zellatmung
die Pflanzen brauchen den auch
also eigentlich ich will damit sagen
eigentlich ist es falsch völlig falsch
zu sagen und es ist alarmistisch zu
sagen die Lunge der Welt stirbt jetzt
das ist völlig falsch also ich
persönlich denke wenn ich
am Amazon nicht in aller erster Linie an
das Klima aber ich denke ich denke an
all die Tiere die da Aussterben von der
Wissenschaft der westlichen Wissenschaft
noch nicht mal entdeckt ja also einer
und man unter nutzt Prinzip ja also all
die Insekten und so weiter die
vielleicht wunderbare Enzyme haben die
einen für großartige Durchbrüche in der
Krebsforschung nutzen können das ist so
der der eine praktische Aspekt aber bei
mir viel stärker ist diese Faszination
für all diese Wesen die seit Millionen
und aber Millionen Jahren auf diesem
Planeten leben und die wir mal eben so
viel ein bisschen beide Land ja und für
ein paar Dollar mehr da weg metzeln und
so weiter als würde uns der Planet
alleine gehören und meine ja furchtvolle
Faszination vor der Natur ja die ist
dann jedes mal aufs tiefste erschüttert
also für mich ist das Abholzen des
Amazonas für diese kurzfristigen Gewinne
ja so etwas wie säkulare Blasphemie ich
bin ja wie du weißt kein Mensch der so
ein Tief an einen menschlichen Gott
glaubt aber ich finde das ist ein
Fahrrad an der Natur und da ist es am
Ende nicht die entscheidendste aller
Fragen ob das in welchem Ausmaß zu
90-8050 Prozent oder wie auch immer für
den klimawandelpunkt
ist das deine Metapher benutzt wird die
so genau meinst Du nicht stimmt die
einfach völlig kritiklos übernommen wird
das ist mein Punkt das ist natürlich
eine Tragödie ist ja gar keine Frage
Journalistin sowas nachher
Richard wir benutzen doch alle ständig
recherchieren können nein aber bis ins
Letzte ist gut Richard ich meine das
sind doch ganz grundlegende
Zusammenhänge ich habe die hat Winter
mal die Ökosystem Wissenschaftler der
Uni Oxford ich zitiere einmal die
Pflanzen des Amazonas benötigen ungefähr
60% des Sauerstoffs bei der Zellatmung
zu ihrer Energieversorgung ja und
Mikroben die die Regenwald Biomasse
abbauen verbrauchen die restlichen 40%
und dann sagt er es interessant
praktisch betrachtet beläuft sich der
Nettobeitrag des Amazonas Ökosystems
nicht nur der Pflanzen wohlgemerkt zum
Sauerstoff auf der Welt auf praktisch 0
das einzig selbst erhalten des System
und das ist doch nicht einer Meinung
eines Experten unter vielen anderen
Wissenschaftler aber es gibt natürlich
auch ganz ganz viele andere auf dem
gleichen Niveau es gibt auch in Arbeit
Leute die sich damit beschäftigen und an
vielen vielen anderen Universitäten denn
Netzt hat einer der Hauptautoren der
Berichte des weltklimaats Zitat es ist
Blödsinn dass der Amazonas eine
Hauptquelle für unseren Sauerstoff ist
und sagt dann der produziert zwar
gigantische Menge Sauerstoff aber
verbraucht ebenso große Mengen und so
weiter genau das Bereiche aber
im Amazonas nicht im ganz großen Stil
CO2
ja aber wie gesagt es ist und produziert
sozusagen im Gegenzug Sauerstoff aber
diesen Sauerstoff aber die Bilder
nicht um die Produktion des Sauerstoffs
allein mir geht's aber um diese
Schlagzeilen die Du zu diesem Thema
hattest leg das mal liegt diese Tatsache
mal die Tatsache dass das ein faktisch
sich selbst erhalten des und sehr
erhaltenswertes großartiges System ist
aber legt das mal sozusagen neben die
Fernsehberichte neben die
Zeitungsartikel neben die Bilder die Du
den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten davon
gesehen hast das ist immer Apokalypse
morgen geht uns quasi die Luft aus und
das ist so dieser Zusammenhang ist so
einfach nicht korrekt und das meine ich
mit adamismus weißt du was ich meine ich
weiß dass du meinst immer zum Schluss
Richard ganz kurz was macht dieser
Alarmismus mit uns ich nehme das schon
in der Politik zum Beispiel ich nehme
das wirklich wahr als Problem mich als
Stifter hat das vor einiger Zeit auch in
der Augsburger Allgemeinen
kommentiert der sagte immer mehr
Politiker begnügen sich damit Probleme
einfach nur zu benennen anstatt sie
wirklich zu lösen und der sagten total
guten Satz das ist bequem das bringt
Aufmerksamkeit ist halt aber auch ein
bisschen dürftig weißt du ich glaube
kein Problem
ich glaube dass ich die meisten
Politiker die Lösung nicht zutrauen
weil in dem Moment wo Du tatsächlich
tatkräftig an etwas herangehst machst du
dir Feinde ja trittst du jemanden auf
die Füße machst ja eventuell schon
Feinde in deiner eigenen Partei nicht
nur der politische Gegner sieht er
schlägt daraus Kapital und verunglimpft
dich sondern auch in der eigenen Partei
kriegst du Widerstand du merkst dass du
heute in einer Partei am besten dann
hoch und durchkommst wenn du nicht allzu
viel veränderst also man kann das am
Beispiel von Angela Merkel die du vorhin
genannt hast ja gerne sagen ich bin ja
in der Zeit als sie regiert hat in
dieser Zeit ganz ganz oft hervorgetreten
und habe sie scharf kritisiert ich habe
diese dieses einlullen und diese
vermeintliche Harmonie und diesen
Zuckerguss der da über Deutschland
gelegt wird der deutsche vielleicht ganz
gut getan hat ja aber der am Ende
natürlich und das haben wir damals ja
auch gesagt und ich war ja nicht der
einzige immer gesagt hat Deutschland
bringt sich um seine Zukunft durch
Harmonisierung
das also all die großen Probleme die
angegangen sind eben nur halbherzig oder
viel zu wenig angegangen sind man hätte
etwas aktive Klimapolitik anbelangt
schon in der merkelzeit sehr sehr viel
mehr machen können als man gemacht hat
aber das ist halt was man dann in der
Politik am erfolgreichsten ist wenn man
sich möglichst wenig Feinde macht und
möglichst wenig Feinde macht man sich
wenn man wirklich wenig verändert
[Musik]
also Richard spannendes Thema finde ich
jedenfalls und auch die Beschäftigung
damit und das ist für mich so das große
Rätsel irgendwie an an diesem Thema an
diesem Phänomen die die diese ja diese
diese dieses Spiel mit der Angst diese
Dauer Aufgeregtheit
meine gerade wir ne wie wir haben Zugang
zu Informationen wie noch nie in der
Geschichte der Menschheit wir könnten es
wirklich besser wissen und trotzdem
leisten wir uns diesen diesen dunklen
schwarzen Blick auf die Welt und sind da
so vereint in so einer falschen
Finsternis dann wirklich das Gefühl es
geht überhaupt nichts mehr voran es wird
immer schlimmer als wir immer
furchtbarer wenn du mal genauer
hinguckst merkst du es wird
glücklicherweise auch an vielen Stellen
besser ja 50 Millionen
Thema die überhaltete Gesellschaft
ich glaube dass das einfach wir haben
ein so hohes Durchschnittsalter alte
Leute haben mehr Angst meinst du er soll
ich meine das ist die Schwärze der Welt
im Eingang des Tunnels also je mehr du
auf den Tod so gehst umso düsterer wird
der Blick
Quatsch wirklich nein nein also ich
meine es gibt sehr optimistische ältere
Leute das ist schon richtig aber es gibt
auch sehr viele Leute schon in meinem
Alter die das Gefühl haben früher war
das meiste besser ja aber weil sie sich
in einem Lebensgefühl nicht mehr
wiederfinden und warum finden Sie sich
da nicht wieder weil sie nicht mehr Teil
dieses Lebensgefühl sind warum sind sie
das nicht weil sie zu alt dafür sind die
Fehler von früher noch mal zu machen und
so weiter keine Lust mehr zu haben und
weil diese Unbedarftheit verloren
gegangen ist und so und ich denke das
hat schon mit dem durchschnittsaltern zu
tun müsste meine Untersuchung machen
eine Untersuchung würde mich
interessieren die wäre dann einfach eine
Korrelation zwischendurchschnittsalter
einer Bevölkerung und Optimismus eines
Landes und das zweite ist große Länder
kleine Länder weil ich habe ja letztens
in der Schweiz jemand kennengelernt im
Buch darüber geschrieben hat vom Charme
kleiner Länder und sagte sinngemäß in
kleinen Ländern ist alles besser und ich
bin ziemlich sicher dass die Bewohner
kleiner Länder optimistischer in die
Zukunft blicken lassen diese beiden
Korrelationen die müsste man untersuchen
am Ende liegt dann wie schwarz man die
Welt sieht oder nicht an der Größe des
Landes und am Alter der
durchschnittsverfahren ja das mit den
kleinen Ländern ist interessant meine
These wäre ein paar kleinen Ländern hast
du halt das Gefühl du kannst schneller
mal Dinge verändern ne so einen großen
Tanker wie Deutschland irgendwie
umzusteuern das ist deutlich schwerer
aber ich habe noch mal ganz kurz ich
werde dich aufhören zum Schluss noch
eine Zahl 2016 ne sind fünf Millionen
kleine Kinder
gestorben Kleinkinder einfach gestorben
unter fünf Jahren das ist traurig und
das ist schlimm und das ist eine große
Tragödie in der ganzen Welt mein
weltweit genau
ich muss in Afrika auch mit eigenen
Augen gesehen das ist fürchterlich das
willst du nicht willst du nicht erleben
aber und das ist eben wiederum der
andere Blick auf die Welt
1990 waren es noch über 11 Millionen die
gestorben sind ich will nur sagen die
fünf Millionen bleiben eine riesige
Tragödie aber trotzdem komme nicht umhin
zu sagen da sind doch Dinge
offensichtlich besser geworden und 80%
der Kinder sind mittlerweile weltweit
geimpft ist auch eine gute Nachricht
hätte ich nie gedacht bevor ich mich
jetzt hier mit diesem Thema beschäftigt
habe und ich finde wir sollten uns öfter
auch die Dinge erzählen die gut laufen
und nicht immer nur die Katastrophe die
wandeln
könntest du dir vorstellen dass es
öffentlich rechtliche
Nachrichtensendungen gibt wo man sagt
wir müssen mindestens so viel gute
Nachrichten drin haben die die schlechte
also so eine Art Quote nee oder wie wäre
es wenn man vor der Tagesschau eine ein
fünf bis zehn minütigen Bericht macht
über Dinge die in der Welt gerade besser
gelaufen die heutige gut gelaufen sind
die heute gut gelaufen sind die jetzt
besser sind als früher ja wo man dann
die Katastrophen Nachrichten in der
Tagesschau sich anhört ich glaube
tatsächlich dass Menschen sich dafür
interessieren würden wenn man mal
erzählen würde was heute alles gut
gelaufen ist wie zum Beispiel eine
Nachricht die gerade vollkommen
untergeht ist du änderst dich ne
Annalena baerbock glaube ich war es die
hat vor sozialen Verwerfungen und vor
Aufständen in diesem vergangenen ja ja
ich habe sie noch nicht gesehen sage ich
jetzt mal so ich weiß nicht wie es bei
dir ist und das zweite ist die die schon
beide gesagt die kommen nicht ja richtig
vielleicht war das so die gasmangelage
ist ausgeblieben ja und der der meltdown
ja das Abschmelzen der deutschen
Industrie hat auch noch nicht
stattgefunden ich will nur sagen
eigentlich sollten uns auch solche guten
Geschichten viel öfter erzählen
wir sollten vielleicht mal eine Folge
machen lauter überraschende gute
Geschichten über den Zustand der Welt
oder Deutschland einfach nur mal oder
Deutschland
was ist richtig gut und knorke an
Deutschland das machen wir richtig ich
freue mich drauf drei Folgen darüber
machen da gibt so viel zu erzählen ja
genau Brandenburg zum Beispiel zum
Beispiel in diesem Sinne Richard ich
danke dir tschüss
[Musik]
Produktion von m hoch 2 und Popstars bei
OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]